y
vale
y yo les quiero hablar de uno de mis
proyectos de investigación y quiero
promover una reflexión de cómo la
tecnología ubicada puede ubicua puede
revolucionar el cuidado de la salud como
lo conocemos actualmente y en particular
voy a hablar de cómo pueden apoyar a los
niños con autismo
la capacidad de la tecnología de
evolucionar rápidamente fue lo que me
atrajo desde muy joven al área de
cómputo ubico el área de cómputo ubico
involucra el uso de sensores celulares
tabletas que reaccionan de manera
automática o son invisibles hacia los
usuarios pues uno pues cuando es joven
el drama en tu vida y pues yo quería
demostrar las capacidades que podemos
tener las mujeres en un área
totalmente técnica y altamente dominada
por hombres
pero después ya una madura me casé aquí
está mi marido pidiendo ayuda en la
iglesia al pobre y nadie lo ayudo
tuvimos un hijo y tu esencia cambia
entonces yo quería ver como mis
conocimientos mis habilidades podían
afectar cambio y mejorar de manera
positiva el mundo en donde vivimos para
quien para mi hijo para mi familia para
mí para todos entonces empecé a
investigar cómo puedo yo con la
tecnología apoyar un problema de
importancia mundial y en particular de
importancia para méxico y para mí uno de
los problemas más importantes es el
cuidado de la salud y además preocupante
en méxico existen 2.1 millones de
mexicanos que no tienen acceso a
servicios de salud los servicios
públicos de salud son deplorables y
nuestra población es mayormente de
adultos mayores lo que quiere decir que
en unos años los servicios de salud
serán insuficientes para dar servicio a
todos a la población mexicana
además existen enfermedades y trastornos
cuyos síntomas son silenciosos nosotros
no los conocemos cuando te diagnostican
es demasiado tarde no existe cura lo
único que puedes hacer es tratamientos
alternativos para mejorar la calidad de
vida del paciente
para mí ha dado una potencial solución a
estos problemas en nuestro modelo actual
de cuidado de salud es el acceso a un
diagnóstico y tratamiento nuevas al
costo que facilite una intervención
temprana y fomente un modelo preventivo
si nadie se enferma sin todos nos
cuidamos somos saludables nadie tendría
por qué enfermarse
y las tecnologías pueden ayudar pueden
cerrar esta brecha entre accesibilidad y
costo todos traemos un celular ahorita y
puede ayudarnos a monitorear problemas
de salud que nosotros podemos tener
en mi trabajo por más de 15 años yo he
mostrado como este tipo de tecnologías
las tecnologías súbitas pueden ayudarnos
a medir los variables fisiológicas como
nuestra respiración la cantidad de agua
que tomamos nuestro nivel de ansiedad y
cómo podemos ayudarnos a encontrar
marcadores bio conductuales para el
diagnóstico de enfermedades específicas
además he mostrado como los videojuegos
o aspectos de gamificación pueden
mejorar la adherencia a especificar
tratamientos específicos el día de hoy
voy a hablar de uno muy importante que
es el cuidado y el diagnóstico de
autismo
el autismo es un trastorno del
desarrollo neurológico que afecta la
socialización y los niños con autismo
exhiben comportamientos repetitivos y
restringidos
las familias que tienen a niños con
autismo y los niños con autismo van a
vivir 30 40 50 años con este problema y
lo que se busca es que el niño que iba
haga una equivalencia entre su edad
funcional y su edad biológica para
poderlo integrar en la sociedad para que
cuando sus padres falten él pueda ser
independiente y pueda vivir una vida
como nosotros lo hacemos
se le llama también trastorno de autismo
porque viene acompañado por múltiples
desórdenes como desorden sensorial
o problemas motrices o déficit de
atención
el día de hoy voy a hablar de los
problemas motrices los niños con autismo
tienen problemas de coordinación no
tienen una buena postura o balance
tienen problemas de autorregulación de
fuerza y de sincronización de tiempo y
el 80% de los niños tienen estos
problemas motrices pero entendamos un
poquito más los problemas de
sincronización de movimientos y control
de fuerza para ello les voy a pedir que
aplaudan al ritmo del sonido listos
aplauda
i
[Aplausos]
que hay más rápido
más lento
[Aplausos]
ese pequeño ejercicio es muy difícil
hacerlo para los niños con autismo si
fue difícil para ustedes fue difícil
para mí coordinar los requiere
demasiadas conexiones neuronales que se
activen para tras transformar el
estímulo audible que en este caso fue el
sonido hacia una instrucción para que yo
mueva a mis extremidades superiores y
con la suficiente fuerza pueda aplaudir
al ritmo de la música y al ritmo del
resto de todos ustedes los niños con
autismo no pueden hacer eso tienen
problemas con la sincronización y con el
control de fuerza por lo que aprendimos
de este ejercicio además es que la
música afecta a nuestro cerebro y existe
una terapia que se llama musicoterapia
neurológica que toma ventaja de la
música y de los instrumentos musicales
para mejorar la sincronización de
movimientos y el control de fuerza de
los niños con autismo esta terapia
requiere ir las personas
40 horas a la semana pagar mucho dinero
por un prólogo o un terapeuta
especializado en esta terapia y hay
padres que no pueden tener acceso a este
tipo de intervenciones lo que nosotros
hicimos fue tomar técnicas de estas
terapias y crear una superficie
interactiva que se llama música flexible
o la llamamos música flexible la música
flexible es una tela spandex táctil e
interactiva que permite a los niños con
autismo hacer música cuando tocan la
tela la pellizcar o la oled o le dan
vuelta
tiene diferentes retos de variación de
fuerza y ritmo y tiene un fondo en
nebulosas con elementos translúcidos del
espacio además de arte la media
automáticamente aspectos relacionados
con la fuerza y con la sincronización de
movimientos nosotros instalamos start
the light y otros prototipos en una
clínica que se llama pasitos que está en
tijuana y que atiende hacer de 60 niños
con autismo para ver su eficacia y la
grabamos con una terapia tradicional
que vendría siendo el estándar de oro
para ver cómo funciona esta herramienta
que nosotros creamos
y lo que encontramos es que esta
herramienta apoya el tratamiento de
niños con autismo y lo pueden utilizar
cualquier maestra que no necesariamente
tenga un entrenamiento en musicoterapia
neurológica o neurología pero que
trabaje en el cuidado de estos niños y
además que mejora de mejor manera esta
herramienta que la terapia tradicional
la sincronización de movimientos el
control de fuerza y la coordinación de
niños con autismo de hecho dos
participantes en nuestro estudio
mejoraron su coordinación al grado de
cuando ya se les aplicó la prueba ya no
presentaba problemas de coordinación
cuando comparamos la interacción de los
niños con autismo con los niños
neuróticos encontramos que su
interacción es diferente como no están
acostumbrados a interactuar con una tela
todos interactuamos con superficies
rígidas como los celulares nos dimos
cuenta que los niños con autismo tienen
las realizar gestos más pequeños más
angostos y más profundos esto quiere
decir que la fuerza puede utilizarse
como una variable para discriminar entre
niños con autismo y niños
con neuróticos el diagnóstico de autismo
es un problema actualmente no conocemos
muchos de los indicadores para
diagnosticar el autismo la fuerza puede
ser uno de ellos si tu hijo o un niño
presenta una fuerza diferente a la de
una persona negro típica
pudiera ser una señal de alarma de
autismo y nosotros demostramos que con
música flexible con una alta precisión
podemos decirte si existe una señal de
alarma cuando el niño interactúa con la
tela por 1.5 minutos
qué es lo que aprendimos de este
proyecto de investigación 1 las
computadoras se pueden doblar dos las
superficies elásticas son eficaces en
apoyar la detección de autismo o darte
una idea de que hay algo diferente y que
necesitas canalizar este niño para las
evaluaciones actualmente no hay
herramientas de este tipo que les ayuden
a los pediatras a de manera rápida ver
si hay un problema con el niño y que
además son eficaces en el tratamiento de
autismo en particular en la mejora de
sus problemas motrices
pero qué es lo que quiero que aprendan
hoy de mi plática
la primera es se pueden recetar las
tecnologías ubicadas actualmente no
existe una brecha entre la tecnología en
ciencias de la computación y la
investigación en medicina y la práctica
médica cuando lo típico es si yo me
enfermé voy al médico y me recetó una
pastilla no es yo voy al médico para que
me explique o me enseñe cómo puedo
prevenir el desarrollar una enfermedad
como el cáncer
detectar en tiempo en tan temprana etapa
una enfermedad como autismo e intervenir
no quiero dar una respuesta al vecino lo
que quiero es que reflexionemos sobre
toda la ventaja que nos puede dar la
tecnología y como de manera oportuna nos
puede ayudar a cambiar la manera en que
nosotros vemos el cuidado de la salud y
tomar un rol más activo en nuestro
propio cuidado y iniciar una
conversación para que los médicos o las
farmacéuticas puedan empezar a voltear a
ver este tipo de tecnología y empezar a
recetar la
[Música]
lo último que quiero que aprendan de mí
es que nuestra vida es un conjunto de
experiencias usen las tuyas sus
habilidades sus conocimientos para
volverse un agente de cambio también el
mundo para bien para tu hijo para tu
familia para ti para todos que mayor
propósito puede haber en tu vida gracias
[Aplausos]